Let's think about what type of
reaction might occur if we
have this molecule
right over here.
I won't go through the
trouble of naming it.
It would take up too much
time in this video.
But it's dissolved
in methanol.
When we talk about what type of
reactions, we're going to
pick between Sn2, Sn1,
E2 and E1 reactions.
Now, maybe the first place to
start or the place I like to
start is to just look at
the solvent itself.
And when we're trying to decide
what type of reaction
will occur, the important thing
to think about is, is
the solvent protic or aprotic?
And if you look at this
solvent right
here, this is methanol.
It is protic.
And in case you don't remember
what protic means, it means
that there are protons flying
around in the solvent, that
they can kind of go loose and
jump around from one molecule
to another.
And the reason why I know that
methanol is protic is because
you have hydrogen
bonded to a very
electronegative atom in oxygen.
So every now and then, in one of
the methanol molecules, the
oxygen can steal hydrogen's
electron.
And then the hydrogen itself,
without the electron, the
hydrogen proton will be flying
around because it
doesn't have a neutron.
So this is a protic solvent.
Now, you might say, well does
anything with a hydrogen,
would that be protic?
And the answer is no.
If you have a bunch of hydrogens
bonded to just
carbons, that is not protic.
Carbon is not so electronegative
that it could
steal a hydrogen's electron
and have the hydrogens
floating around.
So a big giveaway is hydrogen
bonded to a very
electronegative atom
like oxygen.
So this is protic.
And when we think about protic
out of all of the reactions we
studied, that favors-- well,
even a better way to think
about it is it disfavors.
So it tells us that it's
unlikely to have an Sn2 or an
E2 reaction.
And the logic there is an Sn2
reaction needs a strong
nucleophile.
An E2 reaction needs
a strong base.
Now, if you have protons flying
around, the nucleophile
or the base is likely to
react with the proton.
It would not be likely
to react with
the substrate itself.
So a protic solution, you're
unlikely to have an Sn2 or E2.
What you are likely to have is
an Sn1 or an E1 reaction.
Both of these need the leaving
group to leave on its own, and
actually, having protons around
might help to stabilize
the leaving group
to some degree.
So it makes Sn2, E2 unlikely,
Sn1, E1 a little more likely.
So far, these are our
good candidates.
Now, the next thing to think
about is to just look at the
leaving group itself,
or see if there is
even a leaving group.
And over here, everything we see
on this molecule is either
a carbon or a hydrogen, except
for this iodine right here.
And we know that iodide is
a good leaving group.
Well, a good leaving group, it
does not make it any less
likely that you'd
have Sn2 or E2.
Both of those can do well with
a good leaving group.
But it's a necessary requirement
for an Sn1 or an
E1 reaction.
Remember, an Sn1 and E1, in both
of them, the first step
is that the leaving group
leaves on its own.
That is the rate-determining
step.
So that's a requirement
for Sn1 or E1, so
it still looks likely.
We haven't seen anything that
would make us think that we
wouldn't have an Sn1 or E1.
This is a good leaving group.
Let me write it here.
Good leaving group.
Now, the last thing that we can
think about right here is
the carbon that we might
be leaving from.
So far, everything is pointing
in the Sn1 and E1 direction,
and kind of the final thing
is when this leaving group
leaves, it's going to form a
carbocation from the carbon
that it's bonded to right now.
And in order for that
carbocation to be reasonably
stable, at minimum it should
be a secondary carbocation
bonded to at least two carbons,
but ideally, it would
be bonded to three carbons.
It would be a tertiary carbon.
Now, the carbon that the leaving
group is bonded to is
a tertiary carbon.
It's bonded to one, two,
three carbons.
so it is a tertiary carbon.
It can actually be a
stable carbocation.
It's a tertiary carbon,
which it once again
favors Sn1 and E1.
So all of the clues here
tell us that Sn1 and E1
are going to happen.
And actually, they'll
both happen.
So let's think about
the mechanism.
In the very first step, the
leaving group leaves in either
one of these reactions.
So if we look at the iodine,
it already has
seven valence electrons.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
And in the first step, the
rate-determining step of the
Sn1 or E1 reaction, the iodine's
going to nab an
electron off the carbon.
I'll do that electron in
green right over there.
That's going to get nabbed onto
iodine to make iodide,
and then that carbon is going to
lose an electron and become
a carbocation.
So after that very first
step, we have something
that looks like this.
So that's our molecule.
Just so it's clear what we did,
this arrow I'll do all
the way over here, so
it's clear that
this is our next step.
And what's happened here?
Our tertiary carbon has
lost its electron.
So now this carbon right here
has a positive charge.
It's a tertiary carbocation.
And now the iodine has
become iodide.
It has left the molecule.
So it had its original seven
valence electrons: one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
It nabbed one more electron
from the carbon and now it
is-- I wanted to do
that in green.
It nabbed one more electron from
the carbon, now it is the
iodide anion.
So this step right
here is common to
both Sn1 and E1 reaction.
The leaving group
has to leave.
Now, after this, they
start to diverge.
In an Sn1, the leaving group
essentially gets substituted
with a weak nucleophile.
In an E1, a weak base strips off
one of the beta hydrogens
and forms an alkene.
So let's do them separately.
So over here, I'm going
to do the Sn1.
And on the right-hand side,
I will do the E1 reaction.
So let me start over here.
So the Sn1 is starting over
here at this step.
I'll just redo this
step over here.
So this has a positive charge.
That has a positive
charge here.
The iodide has left.
I don't have to draw all its
valence electrons anymore.
And what's going
to happen next?
We're going to get substituted
with the weak base, and the
weak base here is actually
the methanol.
The weak base here
is the methanol.
So let me draw some
methanol here.
It's got two unbonded pairs of
electrons and one of them,
it's a weak base.
It was willing to give
an electron.
It has a partial negative
charge over here because
oxygen is electronegative, but
it doesn't have a full
negative charge, so it's not
a strong nucleophile.
But it can donate an electron
to this carbocation, and
that's what is going
to happen.
It will donate an electron
to this carbocation.
And then after that happens,
it will look like this.
That's our original molecule.
Now this magenta electron
has been donated to the
carbocation.
The other end of it is this blue
electron right here on
the oxygen.
It is now bonded.
That is our oxygen.
Here's that other pair of
electrons on that oxygen, and
it is bonded to a hydrogen
and a methyl group.
And then the last step of this
is another weak base might be
able to come and nab off the
hydrogen proton right there.
Oh, I want to be very
clear here.
The oxygen was neutral.
The methanol here is neutral.
It is giving away an electron
to the carbocation.
The carbocation had a positive
charge because it had lost it
originally.
Now it gets an electron back.
It becomes neutral.
The methanol, on the other hand,
was neutral, gives away
an electron, so now it becomes--
it now is positive.
So now you might have
another methanol.
You might have another methanol
molecule sitting out
here someplace that might also
nab the proton off of this
positive ion.
So this one right here,
it would nab it or it
would bond with it.
It would give the electron to
the hydrogen proton, really.
The hydrogen's electron gets
nabbed by the oxygen, and so
then that becomes neutral.
So in the final step, it'll
all look like this.
We have that over here.
The methanol that had originally
bonded has lost its
hydrogen, so it looks
like this.
We just have the oxygen
and the CH3 there.
It is now neutral because it
gained an electron when that
hydrogen proton was nabbed.
So if you wanted to draw it,
it has actually those two
extra electrons,
just like that.
And if you want to draw this
last methanol, it's now a
positive cation, so it
looks like this.
So it's OH, CH3, H, and then
it has unbonded pair right
there, and now this has
a positive charge.
So that was the Sn1 reaction.
Now, the other reaction that's
going to occur is the E1.
Once again, our first
step-- nope, I
didn't want to do that.
Our first step looks
like that.
So that is our first step.
Let me get everything
straight.
So the leaving group had left.
So in each situation, the
leaving group had left.
Our iodide is up here.
And in an E1 reaction, you
don't get substituted.
What happens is one of the beta
carbons gets a hydrogen
swiped off of it
by a weak base.
Now, let's think about what
a beta carbon is.
The alpha carbon is the
carbocation carbon.
That's right over there.
That's the alpha carbon.
Beta carbons are one
carbon away.
So this is a beta carbon, this
is a beta carbon, and then
that is a beta carbon.
Now, this carbon over here is
not bonded to any hydrogens.
It's only bonded to
other carbons.
So that one cannot lose
any hydrogens.
And then we have to pick between
this carbon that's
bonded to three hydrogens and
this carbon that's actually
bonded to two hydrogens.
I didn't draw it before, but
it's implicitly there.
It's bonded to two hydrogens.
Now Zaitsev's rule tells us that
the dominating product is
going to be produced when the
carbon that has less hydrogens
loses a hydrogen.
So out of this, this carbon
has two hydrogens,
this one has three.
So the one that's going to lose
the hydrogen to the base,
or more likely to lose the
hydrogen to the base, is the
one that has two hydrogens, not
three, the fewer hydrogens.
So our base in this case is once
again the methanol, acted
as a nucleophile in the
Sn1, acted as a weak
nucleophile in Sn1.
Now it'll act as a weak base.
So we have methanol
right over here.
That's a hydrogen.
CH3 has some electrons
right over here.
It has a partial negative
charge.
It will give one of the
electrons to the hydrogen,
just to the hydrogen proton.
The hydrogen's not going to
take its electron with it.
That electron is then going to
be given to the carbocation to
make it neutral, and it will
form a double bond.
So after that happens, we
are left with something
that looks like this.
This was our original
molecule.
Now, this carbon right
here in yellow, it
has lost its hydrogen.
This hydrogen back here
is still there.
I could draw it if I like.
I don't need to.
It just makes the thing messy.
But it has now formed a double
bond with the primary carbon.
It has now formed
a double bond.
That electron that had bonded
with the hydrogen was now
given to the carbocation.
It has a double bond
with that.
And then you have your methanol
has now turned into a
positive ion.
It has now turned into
a positive ion: CH3.
And now it has this bond.
It has this bond with
the hydrogen.
I'll even make that electron
that it gave away in magenta.
And then it has that extra
lone pair of electrons.
So, in this circumstance, we
looked at all of the clues.
All of the clues were
against Sn2 and E2.
They favored Sn1 and E1.
So if you were to actually
make this, if you were to
actually try to see what happens
is this reaction, you
would get products of both Sn1
and E1 reactions, these
products and these products
over here.